[Music]
hi guys
please hit the like button it helps the
youtube algorithm see my videos
thanks guys the hyperion canters by dan
simmons
consists of four books hyperion the fall
of hyperion
endemian and the rise of endemian the
first book of the series opens
up in the 29th century and follows seven
humans as they make the journey to the
outback world of hyperion
in order to partake in the strike
pilgrimage
the techno core the amalgamation of all
cinti and ai
have dubious motivations throughout much
of the books the hegemony of man
maintains a seeming alliance with the
core
and the core has also gifted several
groundbreaking technologies to humanity
the techno core advises the hegemony
through avatars of its own creation
using cybrids beings that are grown from
human dna
but whose true being exists inside of
the technocore
itself the technocore also manages the
all thing
in real time in this time humans of the
hegemony
were all linked through the all thing
through the all thing they could vote on
legislation
communicate with each other with ease
and instantaneously access whatever
information they needed
but this was only possible on worlds
connected by fatline technology
the world of hyperion was one of the
hundreds of inhabited worlds of the
galactic hegemony
which was not connected by firecaster or
fatline technology
because of this journeys to the world of
hyperion had to be made by way of
conventional space travel
at the start of hyperion seven pilgrims
have been chosen by the strike church
also known as the church of the final
atonement to partake in the shrike
pilgrimage
the strike is a legendary being that
appeared on hyperion
at the same time as the mysterious
objects known as the time tombs
which were believed to have been sent
backwards in time
from some distant future point the
strike church believed that the strike
was the lord of pain and would one day
be unleashed upon the universe to end
the human race
the church of the final atonement had
granted many believers the opportunity
to enter into strike territory
undertaking the pilgrimage on the world
of hyperion
only death had waited for them our seven
pilgrims in the beginning of this series
are believed to be the final seven who
will ever take this pilgrimage
due to the fact that the anti-entropic
fields surrounding the time tombs
are expanding and the strike's territory
is increasing
whereas previously it had been bound to
a single area on hyperion
each of the pilgrims has a different
reason for journeying into strike
territory
though they are all going into it with
the understanding that they will all
likely die
during his 11 years as consul on that
distant and enigmatic
world the mysterious church of the
strike
had allowed a dozen barges of off-world
pilgrims to depart for
the wind-swept barons around the time
tombs north of the mountains
no one had returned the seven pilgrims
are as follows
father hoyt a priest of the catholic
church
colonel fedman cassad a former soldier
of force
the hegemony's military a poet by the
name of martin salinas
who had been born on earth before its
destruction
saw weintraub and his now infant
daughter rachel
who has a strange illness which forces
her to age backwards in time
ron lamia a private investigator who had
been rescued by the church of the final
atonement
marin aspic the consul and hetmasteen
a templar who is in fact the captain of
the living tree ship which transports
them
to the world of hyperion the first book
in the hyperion cantos is based on the
structure of jeffrey chaucer's
canterbury tells
during their journey each of the seven
pilgrims takes turns
recounting the strange events which led
them to be on the strike pilgrimage
at the same time these seven partake in
the pilgrimage
an ouster attack is underway the ousters
were among the humans in the universe
not under the influence of the galactic
hegemony
the ousters had inhabited many different
kinds of worlds
and augmented themselves to fit the
various environments in which they lived
which caused them to seem less human to
the members of the hegemony
the first book in the series concludes
after each of the seven pilgrims
have finished recounting their harrowing
tales each of which unveils more about
this universe
the world of hyperion plays some key
role in each of the stories
at the end of the book the pilgrims are
finally approaching the time tombs
known to be guarded by the being known
as the strike
after a long and dangerous journey on
the world of hyperion
during an ouster attack from above the
second book
fall of hyperion starts up directly
following the events of the first book
and concludes the story of the seven
pilgrims
thank you guys for watching make sure
you like and subscribe for more science
fiction lore
you